foreign
which mental model or helpful tool do
you often go back to regarding
prioritizing projects and things you
want to pursue
I'll keep it at that so
I have one really simple question that
Echoes also
a guest I've had on there's a very good
chance that I adapted this from Gary
Keller so Gary
is
legendary in the world of Real Estate
he is the co-founder chairman and CEO of
Keller Williams the world's largest real
estate franchise by agent count
2019 KW which also ranks number one in
units and sales volume the US was named
by fast company as the most Innovative
company in real estate so Gary is a
fascinating fascinating character you
can find him on Twitter at Gary Keller
and
the name of this podcast episode is how
to focus on the one important thing Gary
Keller how to focus on the one important
thing I'd recommend folks listen to this
he also has a book called The one thing
subtitle the surprisingly simple truth
behind extraordinary results
and
I believe the question that I ask myself
is adapted from this but I can't say
that with 100 certainty and that
question is this
in this list of things five or six or
ten things whatever your list of
priorities might be or to Do's which of
these if done make other things or all
of these things
either irrelevant or easier to do
and so look at this list of 10 things
which of these if done
make other items on this list hopefully
many or all of them easier to do
or irrelevant
and that is my sorting function that's
it now on top of that let's just say
that doesn't yield the clarity I'm
hoping for I could look at that list
again and ask myself which of these
if done or brought to the next Milestone
would leave me feeling proudest at the
end of the day
I know people who do this with workouts
I know CrossFit Champions who do this
with certain types of workouts just
asking yourself which of these if done
or pushed to the next Milestone would
leave me feeling proudest at the end of
the day that's another one and a third
would be if you're trying to choose
between say major projects you've got
this branching tree and you have three
different professional options let's
just say different projects different
Endeavors joint ventures whatever
creative projects I'll ask myself which
of these
even if it fails can be the greatest
success and that's a success in terms of
new skills
new relationships or deepened
relationships
and also Just Energy
which of which of these will give me the
most energy will I be most energized by
so I'll repeat that
three options having trouble choosing
between them let's just say they're
creative projects
which of these can be a success for me
even if it fails let's say the launch
doesn't work people don't want to buy it
Whatever It Is in terms of new skills
or resurrecting old skills in in the
case of me choosing my new absurd art
project right is resurrecting old skills
and uh so resurrecting old skills or
news developing new skills developing
new relationships or deepening current
relationships and then providing Life
Energy energizing you that is how I've
decided to spend so much time over the
last say six to 12 months on this this
hair Branch thing that'll come out in
the next few months
which absolutely could be
a flop on every commercial slash
Financial level so that's part of what
makes it kind of exciting to me honestly
so we'll see we'll see how it goes uh
John said the lead Domino exactly
choosing the right Domino to tip over
the tips over many others